well tonight we are getting a better
picture of how many people were
vaccinated ahead of monday's raiders
game remember those long lines around
allegiant stadium monday night christian
costa is joining us in studio with a
breakdown of data that really shows
raider nation spirit that's right brian
well the raiders announced fans can come
to the game if they are vaccinated now
early numbers show about 300 people got
the covet 19 shot on game day but today
those numbers soaring take a look here
according to the raiders more than 6 000
people received their first moderna or
pfizer vaccine either on site or on game
day or basically around the valley now
that number
also we want to show you here 10 000
people that's how many people use the
alternate screening area that's
basically where folks can get assistance
setting up the clear app and overall 7
000 people use the screening area on a
game day so just incredible numbers here
that we are
getting uh from the raiders today now
also we want to tell you that uh overall
numbers show how far people are
basically willing to go to watch their
favorite team play remember this was the
first time the raiders had fans at the
game so as we move forward proof of
vaccinations or getting your shot at
event could be the new norm christian
gossip is 8 news now